Jameel muggle checks in on his workers
after the brexit shock what will be now
generally I don't think we really
understand what's going to happen muggle
engineering produces parts for the auto
industry everything from flow regulators
to parking brakes many of the workers at
its two British plants come from Eastern
Europe now they fear for their jobs
Gami Amaka
wants to keep employing people in the UK
but his clients are mainly in the EU as
soon as we know something we'll let you
know as well like I didn't run before I
didn't before but yeah I say well you
know you don't need to work be worried
from our point of view he tries to sound
confident and comfort his workers but
the decision is not his alone it also
depends on the deal Britain negotiates
with the EU and his customers wishes if
the customer will put pressure on us to
move something we will have to do it I
hope they want and I hope that we can
get there the right deal for the UK as
well as the rest of Europe that we can
keep movement of labour and and goods
but what if that doesn't happen the
British people are worried and not just
the bankers in London bread's it means
changing conditions and uncertainty for
many industries not least because the
negotiations on access to the European
single market could take years
in terms of jobless rates there's
something like three million jobs in the
UK that are either directly or
indirectly relying on our export to the
EU so all of those are obviously at risk
he expects conditions to worsen for
those who manage to stay employed and
good jobs will be harder to come by
those will be replaced by jobs that are
much less secure they may be in zero
hours contracts there's likely to be
lower pay and so the sort of the quality
of overall employment would suffer
tourism is one of the few industries
that could profit from brexit the pounds
loss in value after the referendum is
making London more attractive to foreign
tourists taxi drivers are hopeful if
foreigners are getting better rate of
exchange there's more likely to come to
Britain so maybe that could work in our
favor a plus point for London cabbies
perhaps but many other British workers
could be heading towards a pretty bleak
future